you know our next guest from the vampire
diaries how to get away with murder and
his role as nathan
in hbo's insecure
please welcome kendrick sampson
thank you very much um
it feels so weird because this was not
like our vernacular back in the day but
i was binging you all last night
i wanted to catch up on everything
that's happening in season five in
insecure we're approaching the season
finale season finale is coming up series
for now i was just gonna stay yeah
series finale you guys just do such a
phenomenal job at showing how human
beings function yeah what's so beautiful
about insecure is it's baked into the
title you have to
to to explore those gray areas that make
us human and that is the best part of it
to me that that's that is
you know so well said you know what i'm
saying it's beautiful to explore that
that is our humanity
i feel
so connected
to i don't even want to say their
characters also
she does that brilliant judd apatow
thing where you know you use like real
names so it kind of transcends you're
like who's the real person
which is great because i mean there's a
reason
that people do that because you want to
break down the barriers of the sort of
fraudulence of acting
and make it more realistic and relatable
and you guys do that so well on the show
you know what i i think about her a lot
with uh you know will smith right with
fresh prince because it was his name and
we were trying it had a hard time
dissociating you know him from the
character and i think that's bled into
all the other characters as well because
i get called nathan all the time it's
usually
somebody yelling at me
um for what i did to issa and then i
have to remind them me and needs to have
a great relationship well you know we
text all the time we're good you know
i'm not nathan please though but also
okay like so you ghosted her is that
what they're upset about ghosting
there's bad communication there's also
just the fact that people want to have
teams you know relationship teams you
know but then it's like she put you in
the friend zone when she cries into your
mouth by the way is like one of my
favorite things in the world i don't
know what it is about women but
if it's like been a while or like we're
just vulnerable like we usually cry like
during a makeout and we're just we i
know we all just want to say like i'm
sorry it's not this isn't representative
of all the feelings i'm feeling you're
like i'm feeling so many feelings
it's a little awkward it's a little
awkward how do you navigate it doesn't
happen every time but it does happen
right and i was happy to see that
represented in a show i don't normally
see that it's like the hot sex scene is
not how it goes every single time i'm
sorry
it's we're humans they're so complex
we're such
intricate creatures i don't even know
how we keep ourselves uncracked like a
little egg every day
i think that's beautiful that's the the
again the essential part of that show
that makes it so beautiful is those
realistic situations where you feel like
it's a voyeuristic experience and it's
always gonna be what you don't expect
well i root for you too because your
back story really spoke to me um as
someone who started young in this
business hello diapers
when you were 10 years old
you told your mom something
yeah i told my mom i wanted to act and
she was like
uh-huh here's the houston chronicle
find an agent so i flipped through the
newspaper and i found
some ads with agencies on them i called
them up
and they called back my mom obviously
because i didn't have my own phone
and we're like your 10 year old son is
setting up an appointment to come in and
interview
to for an agent you know is this okay
and she's like yeah as long as he does
the work and that's how she's always
been she says if you do the work i'll
support it and i did and then you moved
to la
and you struggled oh yeah when i was 18
i moved to la
and i got all my ducks in a row i was
like i'm gonna get this apartment i'm
gonna get whatever
it was an apartment it was a room in
somebody's house which was very weird
for me coming from texas but uh i got
kicked out i got kicked out and
within a month not even a month and i
had to live out of my car for a couple
months going from place to place on
people's couches you know whatever have
my whole life packed up in this in the
back of my car
and finally you know i had met this
woman in church who a lot of people
think is my biological grandma because
we look just alike you know we've spent
so much time together i lived with her
for five six years
and she was my roommate
met her in church she she knew i didn't
have anybody i might shed a little tear
because she um passed last year because
of covet
in december so it's coming up on the
anniversary but i didn't have anybody to
celebrate my birthday with so she made
me a meal for my birthday and that's
when she offered to if i could stay with
her for a while while i get back on my
feet and um you know then it was five
beautiful years after that that was my
roommate my 88 89 90 year old roommate
and it kept going and
uh
and what is her name yeah
you called her a name yeah but she has
another name what was your name
but um she told me and this is the funny
thing she told me when i moved in
i'm trying not to cry uh she told me
when i moved in that i couldn't call her
by her name i had to call her something
else everybody else calls her mom or has
some sort of endearing nickname for i'm
from the country you know i'm like i it
took me forever and she also couldn't
remember my name so she would just
sometimes look at me and go
[Laughter]
she called me kenneth she called me
kendall she called me henry she called
me everything and i would just do the
same thing because i didn't know what to
call her but her name miss hanoi
something misses her nor something you
know so i would go
excuse me
you know
and then finally i thought about it i'm
like i'm country you know
my grandma had passed a couple years
before so i my maw was freed up and i
started calling her mama and now there
are so many people in la who don't know
her name
they just know mama mama yeah
i think your mom and mama are these
wonderful angels oh yes who gave you
these incredible values and we root for
you all the more because you took
not the path of least resistance you
took the hard road i was i'll say this
when i moved to la i had an intention of
connecting with black folks more because
there was so much racism in the industry
and in texas and i thought i was going
to get to l.a and there would be no
racism or less racism i was fooled but i
was surrounded by all these amazing
black women um who introduced me to
black male figures that would you know
um
inspire me and make sure that i was fed
and introduced me to families and such
and
and it's exactly what you said i learned
nothing learned nothing more than you
have to be really intentional about
building your community around you based
in in good values because all their
whole and it has to be rooted in
liberation because their whole
objective with me was to make sure that
i was fed that i was cared for and that
i was more liberated than they were
coming up
and
there's nothing else that i could
i have nothing else to credit to my
success
because they created the environment
that i could grow in
thank you thank you for sharing that
thank you for teaching us
so much of it is again sharing our
stories and matriculating that life
experience everybody has a story to tell
thank you for sharing every bit of yours
and we are rooting you on alongside of
it
thank you
we'll air next sunday december 26 on hbo
and it's available to stream on hbo max
of course oh i don't want this show to
go away i'm so glad it gave us all these
years of what it did
[Music]
you